cuál es la imagen del polígono siguiente
bajo la rotación de 270 grados entonces
esto de aquí es una transformación y
bueno al menos en el contexto de este
ejercicio cuando se refieren a una
rotación se refieren a una rotación
alrededor del origen del punto 0,0 vale
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es rotar
esta figura 270 grados y recordemos que
tenemos que hacerlo en la dirección
positiva de los ángulos que es la misma
dirección en la cual se miden por
ejemplo las funciones trigonométricas
vale bueno teniendo esto en mente voy a
tomar este punto de acá que es fácil ver
cómo va rotando y lo voy a girar
entonces tengo que hacer que gire 270
ahí van 90 acá cuando llega aquí aquí
arriba van 180 y si llega hasta acá
llega a 270 entonces eso debería ser la
respuesta muy bien vamos a hacer algunos
más
dice cuál es la imagen del polígono
siguiente bajo la rotación de 90 grados
misma idea tenemos que rotar ahora 90
grados el que es fácil rotar es este de
acá entonces lo agarramos y giramos
hasta que llegue aquí
ahí están 90 grados vale comprobar
respuesta ok vamos a hacer uno más ahora
nos preguntan algo diferente dice cuál
es la transformación que rota la figura
azul a la figura anaranjada punteada
entonces ahora necesitamos concentrarnos
un poco más y visualizar lo que está
sucediendo la forma en la cual se puede
hacer esto es tomar algunos de los
puntos digamos este de aquí que hace el
ángulo más pequeño y ver a dónde se fue
este punto está apuntando arriba a la
izquierda y ahora está apuntando abajo a
la izquierda entonces roto 90 grados
verdad para que este pase hacia acá
tenemos que girar 90 grados entonces la
respuesta sería que la transformación es
la de 90 grados
muy bien